this is a production of Cornell
University
so well let's get let's get started
thanks everyone here for showing up for
more than the food took time out to come
here today that's a great thing it's
trying to control my view of the screen
here I haven't figured it out yet there
we go so when I was asked to put this
talk together in this kind of general
area of light and plant health I
wondered really how far back I should go
because I've been working in this area
for a long time Chris was very kind not
to tell you when I started but it was
well over 20 years ago realistically
I've got about 35 minutes to get to the
point so I'm I'm feeling the pressure to
be brief and succinct but I want to make
sure before I get into the actual work
that everyone's aware that this is not
all my work I had a lot of help I'm one
member of a team of scientists that's
spread across the United States and and
Europe across several institutions
countries even corporations there are
two units that are very important to the
work that are in Norway NMB you that's
the National Agricultural University of
Norway and me Bo which is their
equivalent of USDA their National
Agricultural Research Service we work
with the lighting Research Center at
Rensselaer Polytechnic Institute in Troy
New York with various lighting companies
Saigo robotics which is a company that
makes autonomous agricultural robots and
the USDA grape genetics research unit at
Geneva as well as the University of
Florida said that's part of the group
that's involved so those are the
institutions that are involved these
these are the people at the institutions
at least some of them it's it's a large
group the individuals in the group move
freely between the institutions we often
conduct our work away from our home base
of operations I work a lot
in Florida so this is not only a large
multidisciplinary multi-institutional
and international group it's a very
engaged group we are into everybody
else's business I've called them a group
of pleasantly involved busy bodies and
that kind of meddlesome engagement and
everybody else's work has worked really
well for us for pushing this area of
research forward now for those of you
that are interested in the peer-reviewed
papers in this area for popular articles
posters contact information for the
various people videos of the technology
educational resources visits to the labs
training collaborative opportunities
we've collected all of that or we've
tried to on the project website which is
called light and Plant Health org so
those are the scientists various
scientists this this is really a
high-altitude view of the science no
microbial pathogens have been attacking
plans for a very long time they have
about a 100 million year head start on
humans they have become pathogens over
an evolutionary scale of time amidst
repeated cycles of light and darkness in
that time these simple organisms have
evolved to sense they interpret and they
use light to direct their development
now the general area of light and plant
pathogens and plant health is really
quite broad so I'm gonna pick one
example of how we can take one of these
evolutionary traits and and really use
it against a pathogen and that one trait
is related to how they deal with
ultraviolet light will move from the
molecular and physiological level up to
field applications with the technology
in about 30 minutes so don't blink
you're gonna miss something important so
honey here we go
the pathogens sense visible light but
they also evolved systems that can
repair the damage to their DNA that's
inflicted by incoming natural UV from
the Sun we now know that those
biochemical and genetic repair
mechanisms are recharged by blue light
they actually use light to drive the
mechanism they don't operate during
darkness so I'm just file that fact away
for now that the repair of UV inflicted
damage to a pathogens DNA is recharged
by blue light and it's reduced during
darkness now light relationships outside
of UV in the visible range are used in a
few present IPM programs where specific
effects of visible light on pathogen
growth and development are used to
forecast infection for example the apple
scab pathogen releases its overwintering
spores primarily during daytime rains
not during nighttime rains the great
powdery mildew pathogen produces its
spores shortly after sunrise and then it
knocks off for the rest of the day the
grape downy mildew pathogen only
produces fur NGO and specific relative
humidity and temperature conditions are
met during night hours now all of those
facts are used in present advisory
systems for these diseases our groups
taking a very different approach we want
to understand the relationships that
have evolved between pathogens and light
and we want to use those specific
relationships directly against a
pathogen and I'll get to how we're doing
that in a moment for now I just want to
mention why we're interested in even
using light to suppress a plant pathogen
in the first place there's many other
things we could be doing so let's just
consider just one pathogen Troup the
powdery mildews my favorite with the
exception of conifers powdery mildews
attack just about everything we grow all
over the world
although fungicides and disease
resistant varieties are really an
important means of control
resistance to fungicides and the ability
of this pathogen group to overcome host
resistance really creates the need for
control measures that are not entirely
dependent on either fungicides or post
resistance now in particular organic
management systems are really
challenged there are very few practical
organic options for controlling powdery
mildews and to make matters of worse
more challenging there's a worldwide
trend towards growing crops in glass
houses and in high tunnels and in plant
factories other controlled environment
systems all of which favor severe
powdery mildew epidemics so the the
long-term goal of the project is really
to exploit light as a natural and
non-chemical means of controlling plant
diseases and even arthropod pests such
as mites with respect to powdery mildews
as far as we can tell all of them use
light to regulate their development and
light can be used in various ways to
disrupt fundamental processes and and
thereby suppress disease now as I
mentioned anytime you move a crop into
protected culture powdery mildews can
become your number-one problem crops
that are seemingly unaffected by powdery
mildews can be very severely diseased
and even killed by the amount of disease
that develops the the conventional
wisdom and folklore often is that the
increased disease is due to more
favorable temperatures and relative
humidity we now know that much of the
consequent increase of disease in
confined agriculture is caused by
fundamental changes to sunlight that are
caused by these structures and the way
we use supplemental lighting there's
nothing in the evolutionary biology of
these organisms it really equips them to
deal with spectral changes that are
caused by the imposition of glass
between them and the Sun likewise their
evolutionary biology was shaped by the
rising and setting of the Sun these are
things that regulate their circadian
clock not electric lighting has a
temporal and spectral distribution that
when you view it from an evolutionary
timescale it's totally unfamiliar to
these pathogens
say a picture's worth a thousand words
so here's one I caught up at Geneva
these are two adjacent research
greenhouses a photograph just after
sunset there's substantial diversity
among lighting systems with respect to
spectral distribution I just want to
reinforce the point that just as you see
a difference in the spectral
distribution of light fungal plant
pathogens have photo sensory and
regulatory systems and they respond
differently to different parts of the
spectrum when we add electric lighting
with spectral characteristics optimized
for plant growth we can ignore the
effect that this has on pathogen growth
now on top of this just about all
commonly used plastics and glass filter
out all incoming shortwave UV light many
alter the spectral distribution of
natural light in particular as they age
eliminating UV light and providing an
abundance of far-red light has the
effect of shifting powdery mildews in
particular into a kind of a reproductive
overdrive and that's a principal reason
why they're so routinely severe within
plastic and glass structures especially
those are that are overlaid with
horticultural lighting it has a lot less
to do with relative humidity and
temperature than we've been led to
believe so let's go back a little bit in
time to the early 1990s that's a little
bit in time to be because I think this
is a fitting example of just how far
we've come in this research just in this
area now both UVB and the shorter
wavelength UVC lamps that are available
have well-known germicidal effects there
are UV lamps all around you and they
have been for over 50 years
they're used in hospital settings in
water treatment systems they're used in
food processing to kill bacteria and
other microorganisms
you can go into public spaces and they
are present and you don't even know it I
don't think we were the first to use UV
to suppress a plant disease it's been
tried many times we did get into the
work early
this is a tractor drawn array of
germicidal UV see lamps that our lab
Cornell
used in 1991 to suppress powdery mildew
on grapevines powdery mildew is the most
destructive disease of grapevines
worldwide the UVC treatments were really
effective but they do foliated the vines
and they also made the grapes look a
little bit like small russet potatoes
now put it mildly that wasn't the
success we had anticipated and so we
pretty much dropped the work fast
forward a mere twenty nine years and
we're at the threshold of an entirely
new approach to controlling plant
diseases we we really got there because
we now have a much better understanding
of pathogen biology pathogen ecology and
because of the pooled engineering
physics and manufacturing expertise of
quite a very diverse project team so
this quote from George Eastman
founded the Eastman Kodak Company just
up the road from us is especially
applicable to the state of our knowledge
in nineteen ninety one versus today said
if you can understand a process you can
control the alternatives now obviously
we needed to know a lot more about light
and plant diseases if we were going to
do more than just FRA grapevines to
control powdery mildew and the first
real breakthrough occurred about eight
years ago when a PhD student on the
research team in Norway made a key
discovery he found that applying UV at
night was much more effective one than
one was a plowed applied during daylight
that students name was Aruba Liza the
Peron some of you may have met him well
when he worked in our lab as a visiting
postdoc back in 2012
that discovery alone allowed us to use a
dose of about ten percent of the amount
required during daylight to achieve the
same degree of disease suppression so
remember back at the
I asked you to file away some
information now we're gonna put that
information to use the reason the
powdery mildew ism among a variety of
other pathogens and even arthropod pests
cannot tolerate UV exposure during night
hours has to do with the fact that they
evolved outside in natural cycles of day
and night not in greenhouses with
electric lighting during the day powdery
mildews repair the damage incurred from
UV exposure as soon as it occurs the
repair mechanism is very efficient and
runs very quickly that repair mechanism
is recharged in the presence of blue
light shortwave UV causes thymine to
themeing bonding in the DNA that changes
DNA from a genetic code to genetic
nonsense and if that bonding is not
reversed in a few hours it's lethal to a
cell kill enough cells you can depress
the growth of a microbial population or
you can kill a multicellular arthropod
pest
you can read a lot about this in
excruciating detail in the peer-reviewed
journal papers but the bottom line for
practical purposes is that powdery
mildews and many other microorganisms
really don't like UV at night that means
right we can kill them with a fraction
of the dose that is required during
daylight hours
we've outfitted two greenhouses at
Geneva with UV lamps to provide research
and demonstration units for the
evaluation of this technology on several
crops all of the greenhouse systems are
automated they operate at night for only
a few minutes at a time in this case
we're using stationary lamps up in the
superstructure of the greenhouse the
lamps could conceivably be retrofitted
to spray booms for larger automated
greenhouses or otherwise linked to a
mobile system and that kind of
innovation in developing various mobile
arrays of lamps is now occurring at
several locations both in the US and
elsewhere where mobile booms and tracked
units and autonomous robots are used to
move the lamp arrays within plant
production structures as well as in
field plantings so those are largely
experimental and demonstration units I
think we're very close to seeing several
systems in widespread commercial use
perhaps within as little as one to two
years there are always going to be
factors though that need to be resolved
before we make the leap from a research
setting to a practical system for
commercial agriculture for each patho
system where we move into this
technology we need to determine what
constitutes an effective dose under
commercial conditions in the way the
crop is produced how that's related to
ground speed during the treatments if
we're talking about mobile lamp arrays
rather than stationary lamps are the
reciprocity issues because of the
interaction between source intensity and
duration of exposure and finally how
does one design a lighting array for
uniform exposure uniform dosing and in
what's such a non uniform environment of
a crop canopy so what I want to do next
is just quickly look at these factors
just one at a time and then we'll pull
it all together in an example of a
working field apparatus
that we're using in in commercial
strawberry production so the the mode of
action of all of the effective
germicidal wavelengths UVC and some of
the longer wavelength UVB is it's
identical
they both damage pathogen DNA in exactly
the same way and successful treatment
depends upon delivering a UV dose that
kills the pathogen and doesn't harm the
plant the efficacy of UV wavelengths
between 250 and 280 nanometers is
similar the effective dose to kill a
powdery mildew within that wave band is
approximately 100 joules per square
meter and I'll get to why that's an
approximate value in just a moment
whenever you compare treatments
involving stationary lamps to lamps on a
mobile boom or other automated mobile
system that issue of reciprocity comes
up in the simplest terms to watts over
one second is the same as 1 watt over 2
seconds it's the same radiant dose the
question is does it have the same
biological effect and that's that's a
simple question but it has to be
answered experimentally in every case
before we can boost UV intensity and
ground speed and assume we're gonna get
the same biological effect from a
mathematically calculated dose no the
reciprocity experiment demonstrated in
this graph indicated that the UV dose
for any degree of kill would remain
constant as we increase the intensity of
the lamp array and decrease time that's
good news it greatly simplifies the
design process within the range of times
and intensities that that we tested
reciprocity does seem to hold
now arrays of stationery lamps that are
suspended statically in a greenhouse are
those arrays are comparatively simple to
design but for large areas a mobile unit
is is much more practical just based on
the number of lamps that are going to be
required in the case where we were
building a unit for a commercial
strawberry production in Florida the
next step was to was to design a lamp
array to maximize the uniformity of the
irradiance throughout the three
dimensional areas surrounding the plant
canopy in this case that's a raised
linear bed of strawberry plants now we
conducted all of this work at the
lighting Research Center at RPI through
the construction building and testing of
prototypes that were built around the
raised bed and plant dimensions that
allowed us to determine the ideal lamp
placement and the density of lamps that
was needed to achieve a desired
intensity and uniformity sounds so
simple it only took six months so these
are two of my colleagues from the
Norwegian University of Life Sciences
that's a rupal i soothe Oparin or soothe
a-- as he prefers and aren't a stance
fond they're visiting the lighting
Research Center at RPI that device
behind them is called an integrating
sphere and it's it's used in lighting
research it's essentially a hollow
reflective sphere you place a lighting
source at its center and a sensor
located any time any place inside that
three-dimensional space is going to read
about the same light intensity
irrespective of its closeness or
distance from the light source and
that's due to the infinite number of
reflectance angles inside that
reflective sphere this picture shows the
end result of the design process a
working field unit that we designed in
2017 for the first large-scale
commercial strawberry field trials now
Eve over each row there's a hemi
cylindrical array of 20 UVC lamps those
are backed by polished
recurved aluminum reflectors that
densely-packed array of lamps and
reflectors produces a large number of
reflectance angles in a way it
replicates the effect of the integrating
sphere so dose throughout the
three-dimensional area of the tunnel is
actually quite uniform irrespective of
the distance of a particular leaf or
fruit to the nearest lamp the multiple
reflectance angles also mean there's
there's excellent exposure of the under
surfaces of many of the leaves in
particular due to the lateral lamps that
are at the bottom of the arch near the
edge of the tunnel so that unit was
operated at a major commercial
strawberry farm in Florida in 2017 the
UVC dose that we used was 85 joules per
square meter we made the applications
twice a week and we started about one
hour after sunset tractor speed was
about five kilometers per hour
we called this unit the dragon it looks
a bit like a runaway toolshed this is a
short video showing what it looks like
underneath the unit during one of the
nighttime applications you can see the
Hemi cylindrical banks of UVC lamps and
the reflectors over each row of plants
the power for the lamps is supplied by a
small generator this was a unit we
designed but it was entirely built and
operated by the farm crew at the test
site that's a place called wish farm in
Duet Florida if you go into a
supermarket around here and a package of
strawberries does not say Driscoll's on
it it probably says wish farm there the
other producer so did the treatments
work I wouldn't be here if they didn't
work so great they work they worked very
well and in fact the UVC dose provided
suppression of powdery mildew across the
duration of the experiment that was
substantially better than the best
fungicide that was used in the trial and
that was a combination of two materials
sold under the trade names of Quintin
Torino we also confirmed in parallel
measurements that the UV treatments did
not reduce plant size or reduce
the yield of harvested berries in fact
it turns out strawberries really a great
crop on which to start this research
it's just about bulletproof it tolerates
inordinately high doses of UV so it's
great to deploy this technology it's
tolerant of high UV from natural sources
as well as these supplemental treatments
so since then we've repeated and
expanded the trials in Florida elsewhere
in North America and in Europe some of
the most intense interest in the UV
technology comes from the strawberry
nursery of Industry they're really under
tremendous pressure to reduce fungicide
use because as a need to prevent the
distribution of cryptically infected
plants that Harbor isolates of powdery
mildew that are pre-selected for high
levels of fungicide resistance and so
we're collaborating with the major
strawberry nursery operations on unruly
on both coasts of North America
including Plant Sciences in California
as well as Driscoll's and Kenny
nurseries in Nova Scotia so we now have
a large enough footprint in multiple
crops that we've attracted the attention
of equipment manufacturers that that
really was our intent I need to get out
of the business of building these things
I build the ones that look like the tool
shed and get back into the business of
discovery that's really with the
scientists on the project to best so
this is a video of what we call the
Dragon 2.0 it's a tractor drawn unit
designed and caught in collaboration
with our colleagues at the lighting
Research Center at RPI and it's an
operation now in a place called fancy
farm in Plant City Florida it looks a
little bit less like a runaway toolshed
you can see we're getting closer to a
commercial production unit now in
addition to the tractor drawn units
there are fully autonomous robotic
carriages that can move the UV lamp
arrays and either field settings are in
high tunnels our principal collaborator
in this work is a company called saga
robotics that's a norwegian company
this image shows one of the heights
trials in Norway the results from Europe
where they have even more severe
problems with fungicide resistance and
fewer fungicide options have been pretty
consistent the the UV treatments
effectively suppress powdery mildew and
in most cases they perform better than
the best available fungicides
and that that pattern of consistent
efficacy of UV against powdery mildew
has been repeatedly demonstrated in
Florida Strawberry Fields either alone
or in combination with various
fungicides so I think we're at the point
now where we don't have to worry about
whether or not the technology is going
to provide efficient or even sustainable
control of powdery mildew it it works
now variously configured UV arrays are
amenable to installation on on any
number of existing structures that are
used in plant production systems
including greenhouse spray booms mobile
picking platforms and mechanical
harvesters and such so this is really
just scratching the surface of what can
be done with UV light I've only
mentioned some of the work on UV
suppression of powdery mildew on
strawberry the same UV treatments work
against powdery mildews on a broad
variety of crops as well as against
arthropod pests
so now I think we're at the point in the
work where this quote from Winston
Winston Churchill applies because I can
stand up in front of an audience and say
how great this all works how easy it
should be for the technology to spread
and how quick early adopters are going
to latch on to this in truth it's going
to take a considerable longer-term
effort to promote the technology to
educate potential end-users and then
really create a system that's going to
sustain itself beyond the lifetime of a
grant funded project or an individual
researcher to make the best use of the
technology we're going to need to
duplicate to some degree something like
the system that allows and sustains the
intelligent use of fungicides or our
resistant varieties in plant protection
so that's where that's where we are
in this work in the present phase where
all of the project partners come
together in an effort to promote the
technology internationally educate
potential end-users advisers extension
personnel commodity specialists as well
as the lighting manufacturers because
they're part of the industry as well and
finally try to move this technology from
an experimental process to a point where
it can be a self-sustaining and more
standard practice in agriculture so we
now have operational tractor drawn units
in New York treating grapevines and low
trellis hops both at Geneva and in 2020
we'll have a unit operationally bully
hill vineyards in Hammondsport we're
working with saga robotics on autonomous
robotic carriages for the UV arrays for
multiple crops
now the saga robot is called Torvald
some of you heard this story before so
don't give it away now I've spent a lot
of time working in Norway the last 20
years and I thought this was a great
marketing idea when I first heard it
named the robot after in legendary
Norseman
Torvald the son abroad I rather the
brother of life Ericsson the Explorer
that was until my host in Norway
informed me that in common Norwegian
usage Torvald is the equivalent of
calling someone bubba so meet our
cutting-edge fully autonomous
ultraviolet robot bubba as i mentioned a
moment ago we're in the business of
discovery one of the latest refinements
and the technology has been to redesign
the lamp array to include reflective UV
reflective curtains at the front and
back of the lamp array sounds so simple
it takes a very special fabric in fact
it's the same reflective material that's
used in navy firefighter suits it's a
bit pricey but it boosts the UV dose by
about 40%
and it provides much better coverage of
the otherwise shaded parts of the canopy
that means we can both go faster and at
the same time get better coverage
now the Torvald robot platform is is
really an interesting concept it takes
our basic array design and it adapts it
to a broad variety of plant canopies
that that basic Hemi cylindrical array
can be broadened it can be made longer
taller and narrower to fit everything
from raised bed strawberries who
tabletop berries to trellis Tomatoes
raspberries grapevines cucurbits green
house roses tree fruit anything that
will fit underneath and with present
battery technology it can move
autonomously a very powerful UV array
nearly twenty miles over plant rows in a
single evening now if you want to know
more about robots and digital
agriculture Paul Fromm who is the chief
scientist at saga
bautex it's gonna be on sabbatic in our
lab for about six months starting in
about eight hours when I pick him up at
the Rochester Airport tonight so it's
gonna be a quite a day of driving for me
we we work with with groups at
Washington State University in Oregon
State University as well and we built a
tractor drawn arrays for wine grapes at
Sierra Cascades strawberry nursery
operation in California we've just
completed work on what looks like
another unit for wine grapes it's
actually designed for greenhouse grown
tabletop strawberries in a foundation
block of their strawberry nursery now I
don't think UV treatments are going to
be the solution for for every problem I
do think we're getting to the stage
where discoveries are occurring at a
greatly accelerated pace rather than
once every 29 years so there are a lot
of people that are now focused on this
area of research and it's the combined
solution of all of these plant
pathological photo biological and
engineering issues that separate a
usable effective and safe apparatus from
from the vineyard fryer that we
developed in 1991 of course what we're
very happy about that
in particular because as we continue to
expand these trials we're also making
more discoveries
so you never really know what you're
gonna see until you look here's one
example from some of our grapevine work
that was led by Lance cattle Davidson uh
this experiment began with powdery
mildew was the target but we found that
the UV treatments were also controlling
a disease called sour rot and they were
doing that better than anything else we
were using now sour rot is a complex
mess involving bacteria fungi and fruit
feeding insects we still don't
understand how UV is accomplishing this
reduction the point is not only was it
very effective it was totally unexpected
we did not think that UV would have any
activity against a complex like this
neither did we expect that UV treatments
would be very effective against the
grape downy mildew pathogen it
represents a very challenging target due
to its intracellular hope of growth in
the host but Surya sub Kota
he's a postdoc in our lab show the
pretreatment of grape vine leaves with
UVC made them resistant to infection for
several days afterwards without phyto
toxicity this is the first time we've
seen a disease suppression that was
caused by UV increasing the resistance
of the host to infection and when he
assessed the levels of downy mildew on
the foliage in our 2019 powdery mildew
than your trials there was indeed a
substantial reduction of downy mildew
both at 100 and 200 joules per square
meter and the level of disease
suppression was again comparable to that
provided by a fungicide standard so
these are really commercially relevant
treatments that provide commercially
relevant degrees of control anybody's
interested there's probably a PhD
project hiding in here for person who
can work out how this is happening
yaaay Rob's program at Geneva as well as
our partners in Norway are now working
on the same low level nighttime doses of
UV to effectively destroy the eggs of
various mite species that attack a broad
range of important plants both in
controlled environments and also in
production systems it's primarily
effective against the egg stage but this
seemed to be residual effects in the
egg-laying capacity of surviving adults
even though the lifespan of the adults
is not affected it does appear to affect
their fecundity there's a lot more you
can do with light besides treating crops
with UV you can use specific wavelengths
to target red and blue light receptors
in any number of developmental processes
and pathogens as we learn more about the
really the unintentional modification of
light in greenhouses high tunnels and
plant factories we can possibly avoid
those features and design the lighting
environment to not exacerbate pest
outbreaks and perhaps even reserve
reverse those effects so in particular
these new and more powerful and less
expensive LEDs that are coming on to the
market are going to allow us to use
light in ways that we're never before
possible one example would be counter
phasing very specific wavelengths in a
way that'll selectively suppress a
pathogen or an insect pest
so let's go through how that might work
in full-spectrum sunlight all
wavelengths are in face solid state LEDs
allow you to do something with light
that pathogens have never seen before
and that's counter phasing or
alternating different wavelengths so
instead of red with blue they see they
see this
entertaining isn't it you'll remember
this it's annoying isn't it
that's because counter phasing or
alternating or flickering red and blue
light messes with your photoreceptors
and your brain chemistry good sticking
back and forth between serotonin and
melatonin in addition to other things
LEDs can be switched a thousand times a
second and faster at that frequency you
might not even visually recognize that
it's happening you'll feel it
that's why flickering LEDs in the
elevator are so annoying
plant pathogens feel the same way the
key to using this is to make it specific
towards a pathogen without disrupting
the photo biology of the plant and we're
not there yet but we're on the right
track
I'll give you one more example it can be
implemented immediately
it doesn't involve adding additional
artificial lighting to a system it just
avoids screening out natural sources of
UV or adding an imbalance of red light
these are low tunnels constructed of a
special fluorocarbon plastic it's called
eff clean clear it's chemically related
to teflon it transmits nearly 100% of
the incoming UV from the Sun in three
years of trials in Florida this plastic
alone completely avoids the stimulation
of powdery mildews that we commonly see
in tunnel produced strawberries so I
started the story by trying to describe
just how many people are working to move
this research area forward most of all I
told you what my mission was uh I came
here to get you interested in this weird
mix of biology epidemiology and
technology I want you to stay interested
in it I want to get you to ask me
questions so in the time remaining we're
gonna see just how well I've done thank
you for inviting me you've been a very
patient and attentive audience I haven't
seen too many people sleeping even
though they fed you beforehand so I'll
be happy to answer any questions you
might have
thank you
[Applause]
my question is it's counseling your soil
varies and I do a lot
California somehow eats far why I don't
agree that health oh I'm sorry
the taste of a California strawberry
beats a Florida strawberry yes no way we
have a disagreement there it has a lot
to do with shipping and it may have
something to do California grows
different varieties but I'm probably not
the expert you want to ask about that
because I don't agree with you I like
Florida strawberries
I like Airy nice talk David appreciated
that I the two examples you gave for
control are both via traffic patterns
what's what's the base of information
that these technologies may work on and
hemily by a tropes are our necro trophic
pathogens we don't have a good example
of high efficacy against something like
botrytis there there are two problems
one is differential sensitivity and not
all crops are similar with respect to
their sensitivity to UV so as I
mentioned strawberries are highly
tolerant of UV we still can't apply a
high enough dose to kill botrytis the
other is positioned botrytis and similar
pathogens are offering internal deep in
the plant and are shielded shortwave UV
light does not penetrate anything very
well so they're removed they're
physically removed from exposure so
those are two challenges we can't
overcome unless we can do something
similar to what is happening with
grapevine downy mildew which is
stimulating plant resistance thank you
bill you know lengthens the dark period
you have any influence you need about
four hours of darkness
after the UV treatment is completed for
for maximum efficacy it will be
effective with less dark but sooner it
receives light after exposure the
quicker the repair mechanism is
activated and begins to repair the
damage
damage is not repaired within four hours
it's almost always lethal so you need to
knock off the treatments about four
hours if you're working at high northern
or southern latitudes in the middle of
summer you run out of night and you only
have a few hours to make these
treatments so that's a challenge
I've picked somebody in the back right
the question is is there blue light in
the UV treatments that what you don't
see of the UV coming out of that you're
seeing a very small amount of visible
light and you're seeing fluorescence off
of any surrounding materials there's not
enough blue light there to reactivate or
continue to operate of the repair
mechanism no sits right so remember the
photo liest repair of UV inflicted
damage uses photons for fuel they drive
the reaction so as soon as the light is
gone the reaction stops completely so
the momentary provision of any amount of
blue light isn't enough to fix the
damage from a high dose of UV so the
even if there was we use the headlights
on the tractor for example that doesn't
interfere with the treatments Steve are
there any deleterious effects of the
wavelength of UV light that you find
infective to people well you notice that
all of you we never have outward facing
lamps in the in the arrays it's always a
closed system and that's specifically
designed to contain the UV energy inside
the array so is there the possibility
that a person would be reckless and
would crawl under the array yes and then
they would be damaged the dose under
there is sufficient to blind a person uh
probably in less than a minute so if
you're crazy and you would like to be
blind
crawl under what if he's right but
generally that that kind of worker
exposure is avoided does it produce
deleterious effects on the plant no not
the way we're using it because we're
operating far below the level it's
phytotoxic
does that answer your question yes okay
yes but do you have any thoughts about
how the utilization of the CUNY
technology might impact the pathogen
ability to evolve to that right so the
question is our pathogen is going to
adapt to this as it becomes more widely
used yeah so the the technology that's
used are low pressure discharge lamps
these were first marketed seventy-five
years ago and they have been in pretty
much constant use and for human health
and food safety and water purification
and air purification during that time
there are no examples over that period
of time of microbial pathogens adapting
to higher doses of UV so we don't have
enough history in plant pathology to say
that that couldn't happen
there's no counterpart in microbiology
to suggest that it's very likely I think
what we can expect is you're going to
see a shift on the philo plane of
organisms that have higher tolerances of
UV and that's that's an area of research
right now I don't know if it's worse
than what we do with fungicides though I
mean we're definitely causing shifts and
Philo plain microbiology by spraying
plants yes but if you don't alter it all
in the visible range and they don't
screen out UV it's not because of their
clear it's because there are special
chemically formulated plastic that
transmits UV so not on a clear plastic
blocks if it's polyethylene blocks 100
percent of incoming UV it's it doesn't
control what it does is it returns it to
the field condition so what makes
powdery mildew a extremely serious
problem on a mildew susceptible
strawberry cultivar is trying to grow it
under plastic that makes that makes
problems worse with any crop because it
screens out UV and it can shift the
spectral distribution of visible light
traditional plastic compared to low
times with UV transgenic compared to
open field those with the fluorocarbon
plastic have the same amount of powdery
mildew as the open field
those under the polyethylene tunnels
that screened out UV were 100% covered
would powdery mildew
yes there's more buyers in California
and greater amounts of particulate in
the air after this and then this is
gonna change car could this impact or is
there anything known about this
impacting infection so there's gonna be
changes in light availability with after
fires all right right I don't be more
general than this Wow you really want me
to speculate so UV so UV dose reaching
the Earth's surface in the UVB range
which is what you would be concerned
about the UVA is it's not a problem UVB
is what's a germicidal and only the
bottom end of the UVB range so the short
of the wavelength the less it penetrates
so there are there are many things other
than fire that would impede UV coming in
dust water vapor a solar angle of many
other things so is the situation in
California becoming worse because of
fires possibly I don't know where that
ranks with respect to just the normal
noise and with respect to daily UV doses
if you just look at a plot of the UV
index over time it's highly variable so
we have a multiplicity of climates
across the globe I'm sure it varies
all right this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu